[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
اشتون كارتر ان القياديه في تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه ابو سياف قتل في اشتباك مع قوات
خاصه امريكيه قرب حقل العمر النفطي في دير
زور بشرق سوريا واضاف كارتر ان ابو سياف
ساعد في توجيه عمليات التنظيم المتعلقه
بالشؤون الماليه والنفط والغاز نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين لماذا تستهدف القوات الامريكيه
تنظيم الدوله وحده رغم ان النظام السوري
يرتكب فضاع اكبر بحق
شعبه وما دلالات اول عمليه كوماندوس بريه
امريكيه داخل الاراضي السوريه
العمليه التي اعلن عنها وزير الدفاع
الامريكي هي الاولى من نوعها التي تنفذها
واحده من القوات الخاصه الامريكيه داخل
الاراضي السوريه رغم تاكيدات الاداره
الامريكيه انها لن تدخل الى الاراضي
السوريه لملاحقه تنظيم الدوله وقد اصدر
البيت الابيض بيانا قال فيه ان الاداره
الامريكيه لم تستشر الحكومه السوريه مسبقا
ولم تنس معها بشان العمليه التي وقعت في
محافظه دير الزور المحاذيه للحدود
العراقيه والتي ادت الى مقتل احد احد كبار
قاده تنظيم الدوله واعتقال
زوجته النفط حقل العمر ليلا تحلق طائرات
امريكيه شرقي سوريا وتحديدا فوق دير الزور
تقوم بعمليه انزال لمجموعه من الكوماندوز
في منطقه سكنيه في حقل العمر النفطي سريعا
ما ينتشرون ويشتبك مع مسلحي تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه هناك يقتلون عددا منهم من بينهم
مقاتل يدعى ابا سياف ويعتقلون زوجه الرجل
الذي وصف لاحقا بانه مسؤول عن اداره
الموارد النفطيه للتنظيم لا يعلن
البنتاجون الخبر فورا فيسارع الاعلام
السوري الى تقديم روايته فيخت طف الفعل
نفسه فاذا القوات السوريه الحكوميه هي من
اشتبكت وقتلت بل ان الاعلام الحكومي لم
يجد حرجا في وصف العمليه بالنوعيه لكن ما
توارد من وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه بعد
ساعات من الاحتفاء السوري بالعمليه
وتبنيها سكب ماء باردا على روايه دمشق
وادعائها النصر فقد تم الانزال والقتل
بايد واسلحه امريكيه وكان لافتا تاكيد
واشنطن انها لم تنسق ابدا مع الحكومه
السوريه وقالت انها لن تسمح بوجود ملاذ
امن لمن وصفتهم بالتهديد للامريكيين او
حلفائهم واصدقائهم ما يفتح باب الاسئله
الصعبه حول تسابق الجانبين على ادعاء
تنفيذ العمليه وتاكيده ما انها تمت ضد عدو
تظهره بياناتهما انه مشترك للصديقين وان
لم تقل ذلك بشكل مباشر وواضح على ان هذا
يظل تفصيلا صغيرا فما لم يقله الطرفان ان
ثمه انزال غير مسبوق تم على الارض يخالف
ما سبق وسوقت واشنطن لحلفائها بان حربها
على تنظيم الدوله مقصوره على الجو وان
شؤون البر والارض متروكه للقوات المحليه
والاهم ان ذلك حدث لامر جلل وان واشنطن لم
تجد حلا لما يعتقد انه خطر محتمل وربما
داهم سوى ارسال جنودها تحت جنح الليل
وانزال في البر السوري لاحباط ذلك اما
الاحتمال الاخر فقد يدرج العمليه في سياق
الاستعراض ليس الا بهدف بعث رسائل لاكثر
من طرف في المنطقه بان تعريف العدو في
العقيده الامريكيه على الارض السوريه هو
ما يسمى الارهاب وتحديدا تنظيم القاعده
ومن هو على يمينها بينما لا يشمل هذا
التعريف الاسد نفسه الذي لم يكف عن قتل
شعبه منذ اكثر من اربع سنوات واشنطن لا
ترى ذلك وربما لا تريد
ايضا لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
واشنطن السيد جيف جوردن المسؤول السابق في
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ومن اسطنبول السيد
احمد ابا زيد الباحث في شؤون الجامعات
الاسلاميه وعبر الهاتف من دمشق السيد شريف
شحاده عضو مجلس الشعب السوري مرحبا بكم
جميعا والسؤال للسيد جيف جوردون سيد جيف
يعني الذي يريد ان يتصدى لمشكله ما يبحث
عن جذر هذه المشكله وباعتراف في الولايات
المتحده ورئيسها فقد الرئيس الاسد شرعيته
منذ زمن ويرتكب ضد شعبه فضاعت اكبر بكثير
من التي يرتكبها تنظيم الدوله هل من
الحكمه استهداف قيادات تنظيم الدوله وترك
نظام الاسد
هكذا
مرحبا اعتقد بان الرئيس اوباما لم يقوم
بما يكفي من من اجل وقف ما يجري في سوريا
فحتى الساعه هناك 250 شخصا قتلهم النظام
السوري وفي ذات الوقت من الاهميه بما
كانان بالنسبه لامريكا ان تقضي على تنظيم
الدوله وجزا من ذلك القضاء عليها يعني
القيام بغارات مثل تلك التي شاهدناها
والتي قاتلت ابو سياب اعتقد ان ذلك مهم
وامريكا يجب ان تواصل حملتها الجويه في
سوريا ضد اهداف تنظيم الدوله وقادته ان
نواصل غارات اي ان تقم القوات الخاصه
بغارات مثل هذا القبيل اذا هذه خطوه مهمه
باتجاه هزيمه تنظيم الدوله لكنها ليست
كافيه وبالتاكيد هذه لا تجيب حول السؤال
المتعلق بسياسه على المدى الطويل باتجاه
بشار الاسد لكنها خطوه بالاتجاه الصحيح
سيد احمد ابا زيد من ضيفنا من اسطنبول من
هو السيد ابو سياف هناك تضارب في الانباء
حول هذا الرجل الاداره الامريكيه تقول انه
قيادي كبير بل تصفه بانه امير النفط
والغاز في تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه بينما
يقول احد خبراء الارهاب طبقا لما ذكرته
صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان هذا الرجل من
القيادات الوسطى ويسهل استبداله سريعا من
قبل
التنظيم بدايه فان الحديث عن ابي سياف نحن
لا نتحدث عن قياده من الصف الاول ولا من
الصف الثاني للتنظيم نحن نتحدث عن مسؤول
مالي
ونفطية الحال عمليه انزال بهذا الحجم واول
عمليه انزال ناجحه ربما في سوريا لابد ان
يستتبعها تصريحات عن وزن العمليه وان
القيادي هو قيادي كبير لكن بطبيعه الحال
ابو سياف ليس من قيادات الصف الاول ولا من
القياديين المعروفين في التنظيم لكن عمليه
اعتقال زوجته ونجاح عمليه الانزال هي اول
عمليه انزال من هذا النوع يجريها التحالف
في سوريا وفي منطقه هي ليست قلبا عسكريا
للتنظيم في سوريا نتحدث عن حقل العمر وعن
منطقه طرفيه لان نتحدث عن الشدادي مثلا او
الرقه او احد المعسكرات للتنظيم لكن لا شك
ان العمليه بهذه السرعه وبهذا النجاح تثبت
قدره على اختراق التنظيم مخابراتيا وعلى
امتلاك معلومات عن تحركاته وعن اجتماعاته
وعن الشخصيات ربما الموجوده في هذه
الاجتماعات ا سيد شريف الشحاده يعني تضارب
او تنازع المسؤوليه عن هذه العمليه بين
الاداره الامريكيه والنظام السوري ماذا
يعني بالنسبه لك
اولا مازال الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد هو
الذي يدا عن شعبه في وجه الحذ الازمات
الارهابيه التي تقوم بها داعش والدول التي
يمولها على راسها السعوديه وقطر وتركيا
وبالتالي ليس رئيس الاسد من يرتكب من
المجازر ثانيا سوريا اعلنت قبل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عن قيام قواتها
العسكريه الباسله ومنها مجموعات قوات
مسلحه بالهجوم على المجموعات الارهابيه
وخاصه على هذه المجموعه التي قتلت منها 40
ارهابي ومعهم ما يسمى ابو تم او ابو سياف
وهو مسؤول النفط يعني بمعنى انه وزير
النفط في مجموعه داعش الارهابيه وبالتالي
سوريا اعلنت وانا اقول لك ان يا استاذ
شريف نحن نعرف ان ان سوريا اعلنت هذا
ونعرف ايضا ان الولايات المتحده اعلنت عكس
ذلك واعلنت انها هي المسؤوله عن هذه
العمليه انا اقول ماذا يعني تضارب
الروايات بهذه الصوره
يعني ماذا تريد دمشق عندما تعلن عن شيء
كهذا ثم تخرج الولايات المتحده وتكذب هذه
الروايه اولا داني اسالك خلال اربع سنوات
ونصف من عمر الازمه والحرب على سوريا متى
قامت الولايات المتحده بعمليه كوماندوس
ومطير في ان تقوم الان الولايات المتحده
وما السبب هناك مجموعات وقاده ارهابيين
كثر اكثر من ابو سياف اب متيم قاموا في
سوريا وكانوا يقومون بعمليات ارهابيه في
سوريا والعراق لماذا الان تتحرك الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اساسا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في الجو لم تتحرك لضرب داعش
فكيف تتحرك الان عبر عمليات كوماندوس انا
اقول لك بصريح العباره هذه العمليه قامت
بها القوات السوريه الخاطه ونفذتها وخت
المقط من الارين لكن يبد ان السينما
الامريكيه وعلى راسها هوليود ما تزال
مصممه وتريد ان تمثل علينا دورا انها
تقاتل الارهاب ونحن نعتقد في سوريا ان راس
را مدبر لراب والولايات المتحده سيد جيف
جوردن سيد جيف جوردون لماذا لم تتحرك
الولايات المتحده لضرب اهداف اكثر اهميه
من السيد ابو سياف من قبل على مدى الصراع
الممتد لاكثر من ثلاثه
اعوام هذا سؤال جيد
ونحن في واشنطن اطرحوا هذا السؤال فكان
علينا ان نقوم بغاره من هذا النوع لسنوات
عديده خال وان نستهدف ونقوم باعمال مهمه
ضد تنظيم الدوله قبل ان يصبح قويا اذا سبب
وراء هذه الغاره هو ان هناك معلومات
استخباريه بمكان تواجد ابو سياف وبالتالي
كان بمقدورهم ان يقوم بهذه العمليه بدون
مخاطر كبيره بخساره المروحيات والجنود
وبالتالي هذه العمليه كانت ناجحه وذلك
ايجابي لكن محمود انت محق فالرئيس اوباما
كان بطيئا ولم يقم بما يكفي والوقت كثي
لكنها خطوه بالاتجاه الصحيح فنحن بحاجه
الى مزيد من الغارات من هذا القبيل
والمزيد من الهجمات الجويه للقضايا على
تنظيم الدوله سيد احمد ابا زيد هل تعتقد
ان مثل هذه الغاره يمكن ان تنال من من
تنظيم الدوله بشكل مؤثر خلال الفتره
القادمه وتنال من ادائه
العسكري بطبيعه الحال التنظيم يعاني من
تراجع عسكري الفتره الاخيره ربما عوضه في
الاسبوع الماضي حين سيطر على اجزاء من
الرمادي وحين نتقدم في باديه تدمر لكنه في
السته اشهر الاخيره فقد الحشد البشري الذي
كان ياتيه من المتطوعين من غير السوريين
وفقد الكثير من القدرات الماليه ومن
قدراتها على التحرك التحرك على الارض بحكم
ضربات بعض الضربات التحالف في بعض المناطق
بطبيعه الحال التحالف الدولي ليس لديه
النيه لانهاء التنظيم في الوقت القريب على
الاقل هناك نيه ل اطاله عمر التنظيم حتى
يبقى
قدر من التوازنات ويبقى قدر من الازمه في
المشرق ليس هناك نيه لحل الازمه في في
سوريا او لانهاء التنظيم او لنهايه
الارهاب الاخر المتمثل بنظام الاسد او
الميليشيات المتحالفه معه التنظيم يتمدد
حاليا في باديه تدمر ولديه نيه بالتقدم
نحو القلمون الشرقي وفي حال استطاع الربط
ما بين الباديه وما بين القلمون الشرقي
فهو يمتلك جغرافيا جديده تستطيع ان تؤمن
له قدرا اكبر من المقاتلين وقدرا من
السلاح بحكم الغنائم العسكريه وقدرا اكبر
من العمليات التي ستتوجه بطبيعه الحال ضد
فصائل الثوار قبل نظام الاسد بطبيعه الحال
هناك تحالف ضمني ما بينهما ضد العدو الاول
الذي قد يتمثل بفصائل الثوار الموجود على
الارض ولا يبدو ل التحالف الدولي نيه
لتحجيم دور التنظيم بقدر ما هي ضربات
تاديبيه او اعلاميه لاظهار القدره على ضرب
التنظيم او اختراقه مخابراتيا بين حين
واخر اها سيد شريف شحاده عندما اعلنت
الولايات المتحده هذه الروايه او روايتها
عن الحادث لم تضف اليها الاشياء التي تبدو
خارقه ك كمقتل 40 من قيادات او 40 من
مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه مثل ما جاء
في الروايه السوريه قالت الولايات المتحده
بوضوح انها استخدمت او شارك في هذه
العمليه 20 من قوات القوات الخاصه
الامريكيه ذهبوا الى سوريا على متن
مروحيات متطوره من طراز بلاك هوك و في 22
اسبري
وقامت بضرب اهدافها بدقه وخطف زوجه السيد
ابو سياف ما الذي يمكن ان تستخدمه او
يستخدمه النظام السوري وهو محاصر تقريبا
في هذه المرحله في اكثر من جبهه لشن عمليه
كهذه لا ابدا انا اك بصريح العباره تستطيع
القوات السوريه الخاصه ان تقوم بعمليات
نوعيه وقد قامت بمسه هذ هذه العمليات
نوعيه في كثير من المناطق الان في موضوع
تدمر على سبيل المثال هناك سوريه اتت الى
تدمر وهي تدافع عن المناطق الاثريه في
تدمر وترد المجموعات الارهابيه هناك ايضا
عمليات نوعيه قامت بها القوات السوريه ما
خلف خطوط المجموعات الارهابيه في كثير من
المناطق تستطيع القوات الخاصه السوريه ان
تبرهن على صدق ما تقول من خلال الاعلان
انها تحتجز مثلا زوجه ابو ابو سياف كما
تقول الولايات
المتحده يعني انا اقول للك ممكن ان تحتجز
الولايات المتحده عن طريق بعض الجواسيس او
بعض العناصر العسكريه زوجه ابو سيار ليست
هذه مشكله لكن المشكله لمن قام في هذه
العمليه انا اؤكد لك ان الاستخبارات
السوريه تعلم كثير من المناطق وتستطيع ان
تقوم هي تش هي تقاتل هذه المجموعات منذ
اربع سنوات ف فلا اعتقد انها لا تعلم في
بعض اماكنهم وعندما تحدثت عن 40 فرد من
عناصر داعش هي لم تقل هم خلاصه داعش قالت
بعض القيادات بمعنى انه ممكن ان يكون هناك
خمسه 10 15 والبقيه يعني افراد لكن كما
قلنا الحكومه السوريه
هي ما ما يمكن ان يتردد في هذا الصدد انه
اذا كانت القوات السوريه بهذه الكفاءه ما
الذي حدث و وجعلها محاصره بهذه الصوره في
المرحله الاخيره وتتكبد الخسائر تلوى
الخسائر في اكثر من جبهه سنواصل هذا
النقاش بطبيعه الحال ولكن بعد فاصل قصير
ابقوا معنا مشاهدينا الاعزاء
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الاعزاء في هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش دلالات اول عمليه بريه
تنفذها قوه امريكيه الخاصه ضد تنظيم
الدوله في الاراضي السوريه اتوجه بالسؤال
الى ضيفي من واشنطن السيد جيف جوردون
المسؤول السابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
سيد جيف هذه يعني هل هي البدايه اول عمليه
من هذا النوع لكن هل هي بدايه لعمليات
ستاتي تباعا من هذا
النوع بالتاكيد يا محمود اعتقد ان هذه
مجرد بدايه سلسله من الغارات كان هناك بعض
الضغط في واشنطن على البيت الابيض لان
يصبح اكثر قوه في مواجهه تنظيم الدوله
وذلك يتمثل بقيام بغارات تقوم بها القوات
الخاصه من العراق الى سوريا وبما ان هذه
الغاره كانت ناجحه وادات القضاء على وزير
النفط والقبض على زوجته وتحرير امراه من
اليزيديين هذا يعني انه سيكون هناك المزيد
من الغارات وانا سعيد بان البيت الابيض في
نهايه المطاف قام بهذا العمل وانجز اكثر
من ذ قبل طيب سيد جيف يعني يعود السؤال
مجددا اذا اذا كانت الولايات المتحده تنوي
شن كل هذه الغارات على تنظيم الدوله اليس
من حق السوريين على المجتمع الدولي وعلى
الولايات المتحده على وجه الخصوص ان يعني
تسهم الولايات المتحده في انقاذهم من
الرئيس الذي يضرب شعبه بالسلاح الكيماوي
احيانا والذي يلقي بالبراميل المتفجره
التي لا تميز بين مدني وبين مقاتل احيانا
اخرى والذي يرتكب الفضاءات الممتده على
مدى 50 عاما هذا النظام ليس بجديد وليس
بغريب على المجتمع
الدولي انا اتفق معك لكن الامر يتعلق
باراده المجتمع الدولي بان يبعث بقوات الى
سوريا يجب ان يبعثوا بقوات بريه الى سوريا
لحمايه الناس وجاد ملذات امنه لهم
وبالتالي القضاء على تنظيم الدوله بشكل
تام اعتقد ان حلفائنا في الناتو يجب ان
يبعثوا قوات وكذلك ان يقوم حلفاؤنا من
العرب ببعث قوات الى هناك هناك تحالف دولي
حاليا يسعى للقضايا على داعش وحمايه الشعب
السوري لكن للاسف لسنا قوات بريه لتقديم
ذلك لان المجتمع الدولي لم يكن لديه
الاراده ولا يود ان يكون له ضحايا في هذه
المعركه وبالتالي هناك تقاعس من طرف
المجتمع الدولي سمح لهذه الكارثه ان تحدث
بخلال المجازر التي يقوم بها بشار الاسد
لاربع سنوات ضد شعبه من خلال هذا الشعب
الذي قام بمظاهرات سلميه وبالتالي نرى
تقاعس من طرف المجتمع الدولي وغياب
الاراده وضعف ادى بداعش لان يكون لدها دور
قوي في سوريا والعراق وهذا امر مخزي
واملوا بان المجتمع الدولي سيتعرض لضغط
القيام بالمزيد في هذا الصدد سيد احمد ابا
زيد هل تعتقد ان هذه الضغوط التي يتحدث
عنها ضيفنا من واشنطن يمكن ان تثمر في
نهايه المطاف تحالفا يقوم باستهداف نظام
بشار الاسد
مباشره في المدى القريب لا اعتقد ان هذا
الاحتمال مطروح بطبيعه الحال فان سياسه
التحالف التي تمتلك ازدواجيه معايير تجاه
تعريف الارهاب والذي يحصره بتنظيم داعش
محسوب بحسابات اجتماعيه على العرب السنه
هي من السياسات التي تنمي وجود داعش والتي
تعطي خطابها مصداقيه عن وجود اطهاد طائفي
في المنطقه ضد العرب السني ودون وجود حل
سياسي وعسكري ايضا منصف لهذه الفئه من
الناس في منطقه المشرق ودون محاباه الحشد
الشعبي او ايران او حتى النظام السوري على
حساب هذه الفئه من من سكان العراق او
سوريا لا يمكن لداعش كظاهره ان تنتهي يمكن
ان تنتهي كتنظيم عسكري من مناطق او اخرى
لكنها كايدول جيا ستبقى قادره على الحشد
والتعبئه واثبات المظلوميه تجاه وجود
الحشد الشعبي في العراق من من جهه او وجود
فصائل ثوريه لم تنجح في اسقاط نظام الاسد
من جهه اخرى كتع قيب اخر على ما قيل فلا
اعتقد ان النظام السوري يمتلك ايا من
تكتيكات الحرب الذكيه او المخابراتيه حتى
يستطيع تنفيذ عمليه بهذه الدقه وعمليه
بهذه السرعه تعتمد على تكتيكات الضرب
السريع والانزال والانسحاب النظام السوري
في استراتيجيته العسكريه او في قدراته هو
يعتمد على الانتقام الموسع ولا القصف
العشوائي لمناطق اغلبها هي مناطق مدنيين
وهذا ربما اشهر من ان يثبت سيد شريف شحاده
يعني ربما من حقك ان ترد على هذه النقطه
وقد ابننا ملاحظه عن مساله مدى كفاءه
القدرات العسكريه للجيش السوري في تنفيذ
مثل هذه العمليات التي يدعي انه يقوم
بتنفيذها
يعني قبل ان اتحدث عن كفاءه الجيش يعني
انتم في الجزيره ما ما تزالون مصرون على
تقديم الكذب على الحكومه السوريه عندما
تقولون الرئيس الاسد والحكومه السوريه
تقصف الشعب السوري بالبراميل المتقشره
والكيماويه بينما الرئيس هذا ربما جذل فات
اوانه وقتل بحثا وصور بالكاميرات وشهد ليس
هناك لدى اي جهه اخرى في سوريا طائرات
حربيه مروحيه
سوريا سلمت مخزونها ان سوريا سلمت مخزونها
من السلاح الكيماوي بينما كل التقارير
تؤكد ان تركيا زودت المجموعات الارهابيه
بغاز الكلور ومع ذلك انتم تريدون ان تشوه
الحقيقه منذ اربع سنوات هل تريد ان تفهمنا
ان ان دوله او نظام مث النظام السوري لا
يستطيع ان يحضر غاز الكلور هذا ببساطه
شديده في معامل شديده البدائيه يعني هذه
تستطيع ستطيع يستطيع طلبه طلبه مدرسه
ثانويه ان يحضروا غاز الكلور ويقومون
يقومون باستخدامه هذه ليست مشكله بالنسبه
للدوله على الاطلاق لا والارهابيين الا
يستطيعون ان ياتوا بالكلور من تركيا ومن
كثير من دول العالم انتم في قطر تمول
الارهاب حتى
اذنكم يعني ا اذا كنت تعتقد انك انك
تستطيع بهذا الكلام ان تحول دفه الحوار او
دفه الحديث للكلام عن قطر اذا كان هناك
برنامج عن قطر سنتحدث عن قطر لكن انا
نتحدث الان عن عمليه عريه تقول الولايات
المتحده انها نفذتها في عمق الاراضي
السوريه ثم تاتي انت وتقول ان النظام
يسيطر وان النظام هو الذي يقوم بهذه
العمليات هل هذا كلام
معقول انا اريد ان تفتحوا يوما من الايام
سجلا كاملا لمن يدعم الارهاب في العالم
حتى تعلم ان قطر والسعوديه وتركيا هي اول
دول في
العالم انك لا تريد ان تجيب عن الاسئله
الخاصه بموضوع
حل لك هذا اذا كنت انت لا تريد الاجابه لك
هذا سيد جيف جوردون هل كانت الولايات
المتحده مشكلتها في سوريا فقط استخدام
الاسلحه الكيماويه ضد الشعب وما ان سلمت
اسلحتها الكيماويه الى الولايات المتحده
او الى المجتمع الدولي انتهت هذه المشكله
عدد الذين قتلوا بالسلاح التقليدي في
سوريا من على يد النظام السوري يا عشرات
اضعاف من قتلوا بالاسلحه
الكيماويه
في واقع الامر كافه الذين يموتون في سوريا
يمثلون مساد سواء ذلك من خلال الاسلحه
الكيميائيه ومن خلال البرامج المتفجره
اعتقد بان الخط الاحمر كان خطا بالنسبه
للرئيس ان تحدث عنهما دون ان يعززه لكن
بشان ما قاله ضيفكم من دمشق فمن المهم ان
تمع ما يقوله النظام لكن لا يمكن ان نثق
بما يقيله على الاطلاق لان النظام
وبشار الاسد يحاول ان يتشبت بالحياه
ويتشبث بالسلطه وهذه مجرد
حكايات لان يثبت شرعيته نستمع اليه لكن لا
نثق به اما بالنسبه للضيف اسطنبول فانا
اتفق معه عندما يتحدث عن الايديولوجيه يجب
ان ندحر ايديولوجيا الجهاديين وان نمنع
تلك العقليه السلفيه فتنظيم الدوله هي
مجرد تفصيل وبعد القضايا على تنظيم الدوله
سيكون هناك تنظيم دوله
موع بعد مجموعات بطريقه لا تنتهي وبالتالي
يجب انق اطرح السؤال اذا على ضيفنا من
اسطنبول في اقل من دقيقه سيد احمد ابا زيد
يعني كثيرا ما شكت المعارضه السوريه
المسلحه من تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
استهداف التنظيم عبر عمليات كهذه الا اترك
لها فسحه تنفيذ عمليات اكثر ايجا وايما
لنظام بشار
الاسد
بطبيعه الحال لم تتوقف المعارك ومناطق
الاشتباك والرباط مع التنظيم بالنسبه
للفصائل الثوريه من ريف حلب الشمالي او او
من خلال عمليات اغتيال في الشداديه وفي
الحسك وفي في دير الزور نفسها ربما هناك
تكتيم اعلامي على بعضها لكن هذه المعارك
لم تتوقف بالنسبه لما قاله الضيف من
واشنطن نعم لابد من القضاء على ايديولوجيا
التطرف لكن هذا التطرف ان عرف باعتباره
التطرف السني فقط فهذا سيخلق البؤر كثيره
اخرى من التطرف التطرف بدايه هو تطرف
الدكتاتوريات بالن في العراق و تطرف
الدكتاتوريات الطائفيه في في العراق وفي
سوريا وفي ايران ودون وجود سياسه حقيقيه
تدعم هذه الثورات الشعبيه التي قامت ضد
انظمه دكتاتوريه طائفيه فلا يمكن القضاء
على وجود التطرف او القضاء على الازمات في
المشرق العربي وسياسه التحالف الدولي
والولايات المتحده الامريكيه خاصه تمتلك
ازدواجيه معايير تخلق بؤرا اخرى من التطرف
مع مع الوقت شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك السيد
احمد ابز زيد الباحث في شؤون الجامعات
الاسلاميه كان معنا من اسطنبول وكان معنا
ايضا من واشنطن السيد جيف جوردون المسؤول
السابق في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه شكرا
جزيلا لك واشكر ضيفنا عبر الهاتف من دمشق
السيد شريف شحاده عضو مجلس الشعب السوري
شكرا جزيلا لكم واشكركم مشاهدينا الاعزاء
بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله تعالى في قراءه
جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد السلام عليكم
ورحمه
[موسيقى]
الله
ا